- Hi everybody.
I'm Maurice Samuels,
the director of the Yale Program
for the Study of Antisemitism,
and I'm very happy to
welcome you here today
to the final Benjamin and
Barbara Zucker lecture
of the academic year.
Today's speaker James or Jake McAuley,
is a bit of a wonder cat.
He earned his BA from Harvard,
and his DPhil in history from Oxford
where he was a Marshall Scholar.
In his 30 short years
he's already been the Paris correspondent
for "The Washington Post,"
and is now a global opinions
contributing columnists there.
I'm happy to say also that
he's been invited next year
to be a Franke fellow
at the "Whitney Humanities
Center" at Yale.
His new book, "The House
of Fragile Things,"
about Jewish art collectors
and in fin-de-siècle France
and the antisemitism they faced,
which he's gonna be talking about today,
was just published by
"Yale University Press"
and it's gotten rave reviews.
"The Wall Street Journal" called
it alluring and disturbing,
which I think is a pretty good description
of the complex world
that the book describes
and the ambivalent emotions
that the book evokes.
I just finished the book
and I have to say that it
manages really brilliantly
to be both scholarly
and extremely readable.
It's a great read.
So, here is how things
are gonna work today.
Jake will speak for about 30 minutes,
then my colleague Alice Kaplan,
sterling professor of French
and the director of the
"Whitney Humanities Center,"
will kick off the discussion
and I will ask Jake questions
that you submit using the Q&A feature
at the bottom of your screen.
Feel free to submit questions
at any point during the talk,
but please don't raise your
hand because we can't see you.
So now without further ado,
I will hand it over to Jake
who I think has some slides also to show.
- That's right.
Thank you so much Maurice for
that very kind introduction,
and it is terrific to be here
with you and Alice today,
both of you helped me so much
in more ways that I can
say here with the book
as I was hustling to finish it
over this past year of
lockdowns and so on.
So, it's a pleasure to
be here with you today
and thank you so much for having me
and for all the kind words about the book.
Which I'm happy to talk a little bit about
with all of you today.
So, as Maurice said,
the book is called "The
House of Fragile Things."
It is a study of a
beleaguered Jewish elite
on the brink of catastrophe.
So kind of following a network
of five intermarried families
between the kind of with Dreyfus,
the Dreyfus affair I should say,
and the arrival of the
second World War in 1940.
And so in that time,
there was of course the first World War,
but also various strains of antisemitism
that targeted these families in public
and always by name and
that sort of hounded them
and that they could never really escape,
given that they were as I
mentioned, this sort of elite,
that basically they were the
custodians of the French Jewish
experience at that time.
And by that I mean,
they were the heads of
the communal organizations
such as the (speaks foreign language)
And they were members of
the French parliament,
like the Reinach family was,
the big defenders of
Dreyfus during the affair,
also the Reinach,
they were the governors
and philanthropists
that supported cultural
life all across France,
such as the Rothschild
and Alphonse the Rothschild in particular.
And so, they are at the heart
of this very particular
experience in a fraught moment.
And so, I mean the complicated thing
is that both
the period of the Dreyfus affair
and the second World War and
then also just the sort of
Jewish experience in France in general,
are such well-trodden
territories in scholarship
as all of us know,
and of course, I'm here today
with with Maurice and Alice
both of whom have written
so much and so well
about all of that.
When I was looking at all of this stuff
I struggled to answer
the question of what was,
what is left to say and what
is sort of a contribution
to be made in the research I was doing.
I think after reading everything I could
and after kind of
brainstorming about what to say
about
this community,
it occurred to me that,
pretty much every single
one of these great families
had bequeath a collection
of art or a family home
intended to be a sort of private
museum to the French state
in the 1920s and thirties.
So, before the war, before the Holocaust,
before the ending that we all know.
And these donations really
seemed to me very interesting
because on the one hand,
they offer sort of multiple
avenues of interpretation.
On the one hand, as collections,
they are expression and then
here I'm indebted to the phrase
of the art historian and you
go name their self portraits
of the collectors themselves, right?
And collections,
there's an enormous literature about this.
Collections exist at the intersection
of the psychological and the social,
there is sort of what a
collector chooses to collect
corresponds to some sort
of subjective aspect
of his or her person,
whether it's a childhood memory,
whether it's a sense of aspiration,
whether it's some kind of strange,
kind of personal desire or,
to use the phrase that I love
from Susan Stewart's
"Study of Collecting,"
it's a sense of longing.
And so there's all of that
sort of hyper personal,
hyper individualistic
components to collecting.
But then also given that
this is a network of
interconnected families
and collectors who have
a very similar background
in the same moment,
there is also the social aspect.
And so, what collectors choose to collect
in a given moment in time
is often a function of what is in style
in that particular time.
And what the style is in a given moment
is also very interesting.
So, for example,
in the Victorian era there
was the revival of the Gothic
in Fantasia France.
The sort of very invoke style
was the Ancien Regime
popularized by the likes of
Julia and Roman Gaul and others.
And I'll talk a little bit
more about that in a minute
when I have my slides up and running
but I thought I would just sort of,
briefly introduce the sort
of general arc of the book
before we go any further.
So, I was always really
interested in these collections
and what they tell us.
And again, there's no simple answer
because we're talking about,
very complicated nuanced individuals
who have any number of different
perspectives and opinions
on the moment that they're living in.
But, as a group,
and I should say also that
each of the families that I consider,
are intermarried and related
through various channels
and so to borrow Loren
Berman's famous phrase
from the seventies, "It's
really a cousin hood."
I mean, they're really all
a big family in a sense.
And so, they all knew each other,
they were all thinking fairly
similarly about their legacies
and this for so many of
them was their legacy.
And so I think that that is
quite rich for interpretation.
And I should say that,
it's interesting because
the characters in the book,
they are all from Jewish families,
but they have a very diverse
array of relationships
to Judaism and Jewishness.
And some are very invested
in religious observance.
Some are communal leaders as I mentioned,
the Rothschild were at one
point ahead of the costliest
Theodore Reinach who is a
big character in the book
and one of my favorites was,
a great sort of theorist of Franco-Judaism
following in the footsteps of the likes of
the hallevies, a generation before.
And he founded the
precursor to the synagogue
that still exists in Paris,
the liberal synagogue
(speaks foreign language)
for those of you who may
be familiar with that.
And so there's that side,
but then there are others who had
no sense of Jewish
identity at the end at all.
And who had converted,
who had married non Jews,
who had kind of distanced themselves
from the tradition of their forefathers.
And it's interesting that
at the end of the day
of course the nature of their identities
it's not up to them to arbitrate,
during the second World War
with Nazi occupation in the Holocaust,
but, it is a sort of,
I realized that on some level
it's a strange grouping.
But, I do think that for so many of them
going through the same lived experience
in the same very fraught
complicated moment,
the collections really
are a profound statement
when taken together.
And I'll show you a little bit
more about what I mean
by that in a minute.
But just,
in general what I try to
do here with this book
is essentially to look at these
collections as expressions
of a kind of evolving
French Jewish identity,
and here I think a lot
about Maurice's work
on the Israelites.
Maurice has considered this
in the terms of fiction,
as a laboratory for the
construction of that very French,
very 19th century Jewish identity.
And I try to do the same
through the realm of material,
culture, and art and objects.
And I hope we can talk a
little bit more about that too
as we go along.
And finally, if the book
has an argument I would say
it's essentially three things.
On the one hand, it's
that the antisemitism,
and I should say also I'm
not the first to go here.
There's been a lot of excellent
scholarship on this front
from the likes of Tom Stammers
at Durham university and others,
that the antisemitism
of both and this Jack
was at least to a certain extent,
largely aesthetic or material in nature.
And by that I mean,
it was a hatred of Jews
expressed through the language
of art and objects and things
and that's very important.
And then the second part
of that argument is that,
for many of these very established,
important French Jewish
families in this time,
their response was also
rendered in the language
of objects and things.
And that is sort of how
I see these collections.
As rejoinders to the
sort of hateful invective
they could never escape.
And finally I really do believe
that these collections are to some extent,
portraits of individual sensibilities,
but also expressions of a
durable French Jewish identity.
That was not mutually exclusive,
and that was very compatible
and that presented
Frenchness and Jewishness,
perhaps even as symbiotic
extensions of each other,
and again, an extremely fraught moment
in which antisemitism was rampant
and there was no escape.
I think very much often of the line
toward the beginning of Proust's,
in search of lost time when
Marcel invites a Jewish friend
over to play after school one
day or something like that,
and his grandfather hums certain tunes.
I believe even from the
holiday opera Lez verse
or something else that could be mistaken.
But the point is,
when the small Jewish boy
comes over to his house
the grandfather hums these tunes
that sort of marked this difference.
And the point of the book in a way is that
all of these collectors lived their lives
to the sound of that music to some extent.
And it was something that
they tried to overcome
and that I really think that
the art and the objects
that they collected
as donations to the state
were meant to put an end
to that once and for all
and to demonstrate
not only a Jewish fidelity
to the French Republic,
but
a sort of profound sense of belonging
and also of contribution to
French cultural patrimony.
So, with that said,
I will now show some slides
and sort of walk you through
a little bit of what's in the book.
So let me just do that real quick.
All right.
And just to be sure, we
can see all of this okay?
Okay. All right.
So, I mentioned as well, a minute ago,
the style that was in Bogue
that many of these collectors prioritized
and that was the style of the NCN regime.
Now of course, the late 19th century,
had any number of different
sort of artistic movements but,
there was a certain rediscovery
of the pre-revolutionary
kind of the fate galore
on the Halcyon days
before the French revolution
of aristocrats and leafy Glades
and kind of carefree a nonchalance,
the whimsy of people like
Workato and Fred Bernard Bouschet
(speaks foreign language)
And what you're looking at right here
is a room from the Moise de Camondo,
and the Camondo family was,
well, is the sort of crux of the book.
and an excellent example of
one of these Jewish families
that embrace this particular period
of the fervent passion.
So the Camondos arrived from
France, or sorry in France
from Constantinople in
the 1860s before 1870.
And they are a wealthy banking family,
they're referred to as the
Rothschilds of the east.
And they essentially begin to
get into the realm of of art
as they get wealthier and
seek to establish themselves
on the Parisian social scene,
and this is the collection
of Moise de Camondo
who's one of the main
characters in my book.
And Moise was truly obsessive
in the way that many collectors become.
I mean, it was essentially
his full-time job
at the end of his life.
All he did was sort of peruse things
that his dealers would send
him or suggest to him and say,
"No."
Most of all And sometimes yes.
And to get him to say yes
it had to adhere exactly to
his sort of temporal vision,
because what he was doing is essentially
trying to recreate the pretty
the kind of guest house
that was Marie Antoinette's
playground at Versailles
on the rhythm also in his family house.
So it was about recreating
the sense of Royal provenance.
And just on that the
Royal provenance is key,
the late 19th century for
so many of these families
and other collectors I should
say, non-Jewish as well.
The revival of this sort
of formerly noble style
in that time was a means of
aspiration and projection right?
So the late 19th century, you
have the emergence of this,
in France we call the
(speaks foreign language)
the big bank era.
And that created a whole class
and there were also wealthy industrialists
and whole new fortunes
being made all the time.
And that created a class of consumers
that desperately wanted the
trappings of worthwhile life
to project an image of cultural refinement
and sophistication that
they may not have been able
to show otherwise.
And so, there is a kind of
aspiration about this style.
This is Moise de Camondo by the way.
And another example,
this is the Chateau Duchamp's
of Milan outside of Paris.
And this is another kind of
important family in the book,
the Cahend'Anvers
they are the family
that co-founded the bank
known as today parody
Baugh, although it's gone
through several transformations
since they created it
with the Bishop's time, the Bishop signs
in the late 19th century,
this is another kind
of this Chateau was restored
by the Cahend'Anvers
and their family.
They bought it in 1895 and restorative
with Desta IO, the architect,
and essentially, you know
what I think was going on here.
And I, I don't know for
sure, but what I think based
on what I have found
in the archives, namely
a kind of historical pamphlet
written about the site
by one of the Cahend'Anvers
their children was a way
of writing Jews into French history
which is a very important
motive as well, with this sort
of collecting and home
design relying on, or an
an object with particular Providences.
That's very important.
So that the Chateau is
an 18th century kind of
(indistinct) that, you
know, was revered by many.
It had played host to Voltaire,
Chateau Briana in its day.
And so, you know, it has
this story of history, right?
And so the Cahend'Anvers
there is buy it, restore it
and then seek to establish themselves
in that kind of long Gerais
historical narrative as natural
and perhaps even inevitable
participants in it.
And I think that that's another
really important element
of what's going on here
with this particular style
in this Jewish elite.
And here is your are
portraits of Mr and Mrs.
Cahend'Anvers and Louis Cahend'Anvers
for those of you who have
read the Hare with Amber eyes
the amazing book
by Edmond Deval about 10 years
ago, Louise Cahend'Anvers
who you can see here is a
big figure in that because
you know, she's a kind of
leading socialite of the time
and she has an affair with Charles FRC
who is another kind of
big Jewish aesthete in this"
Just to give a sense, I mean,
I have a lot in the book
about portraits and about
the way specifically women
are kind of objectified
and treated as art
objects by their families
specifically the men and their families.
This is one of several Renoir
portraits that ran more
did have the candle and their family.
These are Alice and
Elizabeth Cahend'Anvers
and Vail and Elizabeth Cahend'Anvers
out who you see in the
blue dress right there.
She ultimately is deported
and murdered in Auschwitz
in 1944 when she's in her
mid sixties and very ill.
So it's a terrible end to the story.
Another example in many ways
my favorite character in the
whole book is Theodore Reinach
who was an amazing academician.
He was a parliamentary deputy
a scholar of antiquity and
also an impassion collector.
So what you have next to
him is the Villa Carrie lows
which is a painstaking
recreation of a second century
Greek delight at Del OSS.
And that was his, that was his passion.
I mean, so Theodore Reinach
were lead defenders of Dreyfus.
They were sort of everywhere
in fantasy France.
I mean, I'm always
surprised that, you know
they had the stature of
essentially the James family
in the U.S I mean, they
were like the William Henry
and Alice, James of
third Republic, France.
And yet very little of
them remains today, even.
I mean, if anything
they just are footnotes in
stories about other people
but at the time, I mean,
they were hugely important.
And I, you know, one
thing I hope comes about
from the book is that
maybe they get a little bit
more attention that they
deserve, but anyways
so Theodore Reinach builds this house
as a kind of refuge in the
time of the Dreyfus affair.
And it is meant to sort of achieve
I would say a kind of
Greek ideal of beauty.
I mean, that's my interpretation.
I don't know how convincing those
of you who will read
the book will find that
but it is, it is my view.
I think that,
Reinach is a guy who,
as I mentioned before
was a great sort of
theorist of French Judaism.
And he essentially seeks
to show that Frenchness was
or is the Jew or the, that,
that the Jewishness was a sort
of Frenchness of antiquity
if that makes any sense that
that Jewishness has this
this kind of unit like
universal Republican aim to it.
And that's his way of
I think showing French
Jewish compatibility
in this like deeply fraught
hostile moment that he lived in, when
for instance, the French military wrongly
accuses a Jewish military
captain of, of treason.
And there are any number
of other antisemitic standards that are so
it's interesting because, you know
the Reinachs were proud Jews always
and proud French Republicans,
and they seem to say
or to suggest that the particular is prior
to the universal meaning that sort
of the universal
citizenship ideal in France
but that the universal can
still be the aspiration
of the particular community.
I think
that that's a very important
interpretation that they made.
And it's one that resonates,
I think, a lot in France today
where of course, as we
all know, citizenship
and identity remain categories
and religion, of course.
So hotly contested and the
boundaries of all of that too.
So I find the right Theodore Reinach
absolutely fascinating for that reason.
Now, just a little bit
about the particular
nature of antisemitism
in the time I mentioned
that there was this sort
of invective based on objects and things.
And you're looking right
here at a picture of Dremel
to home who needs no introduction,
but just in a sentence
he was one of the most
virulent antisemites
in European history before the Holocaust.
And he was, I mean, it's often forgotten.
And I, here, I draw on the
remarkable biography of Dremel
by Gregoire Kaufman, and
also some of the early works
of Phil Nord at Princeton,
but it's, it's often
forgotten the Dremel
was an antiquarian when
he started out.
So he has this, this
real nostalgia to him.
That's I think so important
for understanding his atrial of Jews.
So he lives longing for a Paris.
That was a simpler Paris.
That was the sort of
old cobblestone streets
before the industrial transformation
of the city in the 19th
century, before the railroads,
before the department stores,
many of which were owned and
operated by Jews, of course.
And so he makes that association between
the kind of ruination of
the Paris of his dreams,
which of course never existed
and what the problems he sees
in his time as being the faults of Jews.
But what's important to keep in mind.
There is that it's a
sort of material affront
that Jews are responsible
first and foremost
for this material desecration
of his ideal city.
And, unfortunately I had to read so much
of his infamous screed and the house read
which came out in 18 at
the end of the 19th century
and basically made a fortune
for the publishing house, flat malleable.
And in each of the chapters,
there's a mention of one
of these families and their
collection, but the collection
in his mind is one of
their greatest offenses
because they're buying objects
that have this French history
and French provenance
that they have no business owning and his
and his eyes and that they're
living in these houses again
like the candles out at that
have, that are not to be owned
by Jews because Jews are somehow always
outside the national narrative
and, you know, for Jumo
and also
for the gold cruel Jews were
somewhat mimetic figures.
You know, they were
facsimiles of Frenchman.
They could never create admire
or appreciate true aesthetic beauty
and everything they created
was ersatz and fake.
And the gong core diaries
have tons of these sort
of vindictive little
vignettes of dinner parties.
They attended at the
homes of these collectors
in my book and drew Moyer as well.
So I try to argue, you know
everyone knows that drama
was a big anti-Semite
but I think it's really
important to understand
the lived experiences of
these characters in the book
these actual Jewish
families, what it was like
and the rhetoric that they
often encountered was an attack
on their material possessions.
And that is I think, a really
really important piece of
the puzzle to keep in mind.
And just briefly, one story to that end
what you're looking at here is the Tiara
of cyto Farnaz or the
so-called TRF sites of Farnaz.
And this is one of the most
tragic stories in the book
I think because it's,
it's a forgery, right?
So Dremel had been arguing
for years that Jews could not know
and detect and admire a true beauty.
And then here was this
forgery that was presented
to the lube museum in
the late 19th century
by a kind of swindler guy from Odessa.
And the guy who made it was,
was Jewish as was the swindler.
And then the Reinach family
at the time was on the
museum advisory board
and in charge of the constant CLT fee
which basically oversaw the acquisitions
and new pieces purchased for collection.
And they bought this
and the Rhine Knox avowedly defended it.
They really believed that it
was a true gold Tiara from cyto
to Farnaz in the early, I think
it's the early BCE period.
Although I forget off the top
of my head and there were
doubts raised by many
but they sort of pushed it
forward because they really
they thought it would be a major coup
for the lube museum and also for them.
But then it turned out to be a disaster.
This was shown it was exposed to be a fake
and the carefully cultivated sensibility
that the family projected
had a major blow.
And for Dremel it was a major vindication.
And you can see here, there
were these postcards basically
you know, with, with obviously
antisemitic caricatures
and the Tiara and Frans
Hals is this is a painting.
This is a kind of inside baseball thing
but this is a painting
that Joseph rhino purchased
at auction, not too long
before the Tiara and the loo.
So it was for the antisemites
of the day, it was vindication
and for the rhinoceros,
it was utter humiliation.
And I realized that there's a lot
of characters and a lot of people in this
but I tell this story just to give a sense
of how high the stakes
were for these objects.
That in theory seemed
like kind of bond bonds
or have sort of little ornaments to put
put aside in a house, but
it was really a matter
of reputation for so many of these people.
And sometimes it went
wrong now, just to conclude
to tell you all a little bit more
about sort of what happens
to this millionaire.
This is a picture of
(indistinct)like many French Jews
and this is a well-trodden territory.
You know, Phillipe Landauer
Derek penciler many have
written about the Jews
of France serving in the first World War
and how it was in a sense to
use fully blender's phrase
the Apogee of the Israelis, the, the
the moment at which Jews felt most proudly
at home in the French Republic.
And these seem (indistinct)
was one of those.
So he enlists in the military
or was drafted in the
military and ultimately dies
in September, 1917, fighting for friends.
He dies behind enemy lines
and Lauren and east France.
And that's where his sister
(indistinct)who later
during the second World War is
arrested with her ex-husband
and two children and
deported to Auschwitz where
they were all murdered and they of pushed.
They go to draw, see the
interment camp outside Paris first
but in a way, the story of
the camel DOE is a microcosm
of the Jewish experience in modern, France
at least before the second World War
you have the immigrant
father who, you know
become super French in
his estimation and who
does everything he can, you
know, he collects passionately.
These Osteon regime
objects that I showed you.
He leaves everything to the state.
His son dies fighting for France.
And then a generation later,
his daughter is murdered
by the same country that
his son died fighting for.
And that he left all of
his worldly goods too.
So it's a very tragic end
to the story, but it just
in a way, it's the, it's the most sort
of illustrative example
that I have in the story.
I think this is a picture of and his son
and he seen this is a picture
of the music demo dough
when it opened in 1936.
And, you know, movies was obsessive
about how everything had to
be run down to the umbrella
stands down to the dust,
how it was to be cleaned.
I mean, he was, he really
was a control freak
as of course, many collectors are.
I mean, he wouldn't, he
refuse to part with Sarah
with basically anything
from his collection, because
you know, after what he had been through
having lost his son and his
wife, it, you got the sense
that the objects were
essentially all that was solid
in the life that had otherwise melted
into air to use the famous
phrase of, of Karl Marx, that
you know, the objects gave a
certain fixity and stability
and structure to an otherwise
cruel outside world.
And there's something
very, very sad about that.
I think this is the,
the room and the camel
and the house that kind
of preserve the faces
of a family that has a
portrait of movies, father
and you can't see it, but there's a little
the little kind of credenza.
There's a portrait of
his sign, a photograph
and then a statue of his daughter.
And that's what you see when
you visit the museum today.
The family was always meant to be part
of it and they, they, they are.
And so it's on the one hand, this
this weird kind of site of
memory, so to speak because
on the one hand, you know,
if you were an art student
it's a great collection
of 18th century art
one of the finest that you
can find, but then also it's
it's the story of a
family and specifically
of a Jewish family in
a very fraught moment.
And you have all of that
working at the same time.
Finally, to that point
about the different levels
of memory you have here, the initial
this is in the Portico share
of the chem window museum.
It's, you know, you can see
that the museum was left in
the honor of (indistinct)
and then it has a small
plaque that was added sometime
in the eighties about what
had happened to Beatrice
the chem window in Auschwitz.
And then finally, you know
this is not Amelia whose
memory has fared very well.
I, I had this photo from
when I was a PhD student
and this is in central
mental lay that kind
of a fancy suburb to the west of Paris
where the (indistinct) really were based.
And this was outside.
I mean, it was then a faded kind
of plaque that had seen
better days to say the least.
And that's sort of all that remains
of the family in public, in France.
And then it was taken down and
in the process of kind of
doing some final fact checking
through the book I spoke with, I guess
official in the mayor's offices
at, in central mental way
just to ask her what the deal
with all that was and was told
that the plaque for the Ryan
ox, which was peeling anyway
was taken down, I think
2015 for a renovation
and that they have no
plans to put it back up.
And again, that is for a
family that was at the heart
of cultural and intellectual
life in the third Republic.
And it's just in a way
a microcosm for the entire,
you know, year of that.
I try to evoke in the
book, and this is finally
a photograph that I love of
(indistinct) and profile taken
not too long before she
was arrested and murdered.
And I think that the, the, the production
of the photo kind of
gets at the mystery of
of what had happened to her.
And in a way, if there's one person
in the book that it's
four, it really is her.
And I, I tried to the best
of my ability to find every
trace that I could, of her
of letters that she had
written and records of her.
And I found only a few, but I don't know.
It's just a, it's a devastating story.
And I, I wish that more people would,
were they more kind of
researchers would look into it?
Cause it's just, it's
really a, an awful story.
So with that, I will
I guess we can do the question part now.
I'm I feel like I'm rambling,
but I appreciate the chance
to talk about the book and right.
So I will stop the PowerPoint right there.
- Thank you, Jake.
It's, it's just gripping to hear
about your book at this time,
as I was listening, I thought
that it draws us in because
it's a reverse fairy tale.
You know, it starts out
with all the glory and the
fantasy in this glittering world
and then it, it ends, you know, in horror.
So I am very eager to
hear about bear, please.
Come on, bill.
Here's a question.
I do think that that what you say
about material antisemitism is important
and I have a few followup questions.
One is, you know, does
it only concern the rich
and then the second question
is, is it just for the French
this material anti-Semitism so for example
you have Wagner saying
that Jews couldn't produce real
art is material antisemitism
of French product or general European?
- No, I think that is
an excellent question.
And I agree that it is not just
a sort of French phenomenon
but I think that in, you know,
those sort of how to put it
in that sort of aesthetic
conversation, there was always
or maybe not always
but there was often an
attempt to, well, yeah, as I
as I was saying to sort of depict the Jew
as the inverse to authentic beauty
to somehow say that the
Jew is a mimetic figure
merely kind of performing
an identity that he
or she can never actually
achieve or understand.
I do think that in, I mean
I think what I try to
do in the book is to say
that while it may not be
distinctly French, this phenomenon
it is really important in
trying to understand the nature
of daily life or these,
these people in the fantasy.
And I think in so many,
you know, often, you know
when we use the term antisemitism,
it actually means very different things
at different moments, right?
So in the enlightenment, it was
often a hostility to Judaism
as a religion that some saw as
sort of backward and the age
of kind of rationality, so to
speak, you know, it means like
in then there was the era
of the socialists who Jews
for perceived capitalistic tendencies.
I mean, the list goes on and
on with the different sort
of meanings at different times.
And what I was trying to show
is that in the fantasy check
there was a very important
sort of material nature
to the critique that these
families were facing now
to your other point, or your
other question, I do think
that this was predominantly
something that these
wealthier kind of more
prominent families faced
as opposed to there are
kind of lesser established
counterparts.
- You can't be a peddler.
You can't be accused of be the victim
of material antisemitism
if you're a peddler.
- Right. Exactly.
I mean, I think there, you
absolutely were accused
of being a fake Frenchman for sure.
But you were not being attacked,
the objects that you under
the homes that you, you had, although-
- It's so interesting because
I had always seen in taggy F
and people like that, that
distinction between the blood
and the racial anti-Semitism,
which I associate with Germany
and the cultural antisemitism
and the story you
tell makes the cultural
antisemitism sound worse
in some ways than the blood antisemitism.
- I mean, I'm not sure it's, it's worse.
It, it just, I don't know, to me
it's that the there's no
escape, it's that, you know
if you follow all of the rules so to speak
there's just nothing you can
do at the end of the day.
Even if you, you truly, I
mean, the other thing, I mean
the gold Corp we're, I should
I should say they were
the ones who presided
over the revival of this sort
of honesty on regime style
and the fantasy check, right?
So they're the ones that make it, that
that sort of lead to the
preside over the register
very what they call the
delicious decadence and, you know
they they're all about that.
And then if you were a family
like (indistinct) there who
did exactly what they said
and bought all
of the pieces that they
identified as valuable, or that
that were somehow worth
having it wasn't good enough.
I mean, nothing.
It was just, it was all for nothing
which is sort of heartbreaking in a way.
- Let me ask you one more
question, then I'll turn it
over to Maurice for
the audience questions.
You know, I've been thinking a lot
about Algeria and the idea of apology
or restitution or
something, and the idea that
confessing a crime doesn't
let the criminal off the hook.
So it seems that there's been
more acknowledgement recently
about what happened to these families
but is there going to be something else?
I mean, is there going to be
an acknowledgement and apology
more plaques the plaque put up?
Is there any activism around these?
- To my knowledge, there is no activism.
I mean, I think as you
mentioned, there, there
there was a lot of movement
in the eighties and nineties
and then it culminates with sharp rocks
big speech at the kind
of formally apologizing
for Francis complicit in the Holocaust.
And then there has been a
very commendable, although
of course it's never enough,
but a commendable effort
like the Metro league
commissioned to identify
stolen paintings and French
music and to give them back.
But, you know, aside from that
from the kind of restitution
claims, which are
by the way only available for
paintings that we can identify
and that we know the
whereabouts of, I don't, I mean
I don't see any other activism,
so it's just, you know, the
the state has done
at least in its own mind,
you know, what it can do.
And then the rest is just what it is.
And it's sort of, it's, there's just a
there's a huge absence there
and that is the worst part of all.
- Yeah. You know, there's a piece
of your book that makes anyone
ask if it could happen today.
Cause some elite group.
- Yeah. I mean, let's just say I couldn't
- Yeah. Okay.
Take it away, Maurice.
- All right.
Well, yeah, thank you for that.
That was just a really
great summary of the book.
And I encourage everybody
to ask questions using
the Q&A function.
There's one to get us started
from our colleague, Katie Trump,
Nour, who asks what became
of the Mo of the Komodo museum
during World War II during
the German occupation.
And then if I could just follow that
up with the question I had
which is you end a book
like one of the last
I think it's the last chapter
before the conclusion is
that what happens to the fate of that port
of the Renoir portrait of the
con kn don't there or girls?
So if you could just tell that story.
- Sure, so briefly, I mean the
Kim lingo museum, like a lot
of these other museums, you,
they, they, it was donated
to the state on the depth of
movies to chem window in 1935.
It opens as a museum in 1936,
it closes during the war
but the collection remains
more or less intact
because it was state property at the time.
And so it's not necessarily the story of
I mean, the, the, I mean, oddly, the
the book that I have
written is not really a book
about spoliation because
a lot of the stuff
in it that the stuff meaning the objects
and the art that was
donated had already been
in kind of French state
collections at the time of the war.
Now, of course there were some
pieces that were still won
but they were alluded
as pieces that belong
to the French government,
not necessarily to
as pieces that belong to Jewish families.
Now that said many of these
families had private collections
on top of what was already
given to the state.
And in those instances, there was a lot
of Nazi theft and kind of horrible stories
the likes of which you have seen in movies
like the woman in gold, etc.
And Maurice brings up
the, the famous portrait
of Iran candles there, which
actually I should have put
in the slideshow, but naturally did not.
But it's the famous portrait
where the young woman is
in profile with kind of red hair.
It's very beautiful, that belong to
because it is a portrait of
her mother, Iran candle there
and her husband who was the, again
I apologize for all the
names and for the fact
that many of the names
are the same, but anyway
it belonged to bear
trees to come on there.
And her husband, Leon,
Reinach this portrait
and it had been given to the lube museum
for safekeeping before the
war, as did many collectors.
It ends up in the Chateau
the sham board with many loose items.
And then it's there the, that the err
the Nazi art task force, seizes it
and the rhinoceros and McKenna
windows never see it again.
It passes briefly through the hands
of Herman Garang it's in
his collection for awhile.
He trades it for something else.
It miraculously survived the war.
And then in 1945 or 46, it's in this
the famous show presided
over by Roosevelt.
The, the woman who basically saved so many
of these Jewish owned
artworks that were stolen
in the trailer, Gordon's
where there's a show put on
basically for any survivors to come
and claim what might still
be there as if they're
if they could recognize it
if they could make some kind of claim.
And so that painting is
in the show, the real life
Erin candles there who had
sort of left the, the community
of these families who had
converted to Catholicism
who hit away in Paris with
her Italian passport all
throughout the war and who, by all intents
and purposes never made any
effort to save her daughter
in any way, despite her
considerable resources
which is just horrible to, to read about.
But anyway, she sees
the painting in the show
she gets it back and, you
know, keep in mind it was a
it was a prize possession
of her daughter who had it
in her living room, in her
apartment, in New York.
Anyway, it ran the real life around
and gets the portrait back.
I mean, it's an easy claim
to make because she, you know
she could say that this
is me, you know, when
I was a little girl, so she
gets it back and then, you know
almost immediately she sells it
but the problem is who she sells it
to or whom she sells it to.
And that is the arms dealer
and mule Burleigh who ran the I'm going
to mispronounce, but the,
or, or client on arms
factory and Zurich during the war.
And you know
this is a guy who collaborated
openly with the Nazis.
I mean, he would say where
he here to defend himself.
And he also provided arms to the allies
but the truth is he made his fortune
in selling arms and war
materials to the Nazis.
And, you know, he w often
was in Paris during the war
buying our dubiously on the black market.
He bought tons of stuff that belonged
to the Rosenberg family,
the great family of dealers.
He was forced to give all that back.
And the luckily Paul
Rosenberg was still around
and after the war got a lot of it back
but so it ran the real life
or in cells, legally, her
her daughter is painting to this man.
And so today the painting remains legally
in the collection of a
former Nazi collaborator.
And there is no restitution
claim that can be made
because it was sold legally.
And it's, it was sold by
the descendant to this man.
And so the painting, which is in a way
one of the only things
that remains of batteries
to Ken window is kind of in
this eternal captivity in a way.
And it's just, it's quite awful to think
about it as you, I don't know.
It really bothers me a lot.
Wow. Yeah.
And it's such a, kind of an
incredible ending to your book.
- So very interesting
question from someone
about whether this story
of Jewish collectors
how French is this story.
So is that, are there
were there major Jewish
collectors in other countries too
in Britain, Germany, you
know, Italy, us even.
- Absolutely it's not a
distinctly French story.
I think.
Well, even that's complicated
to say, because I mean
I think as you go from country to country
the styles of what was collected
and, you know, the, the
the nature of the collections
change, I think given
that we are in France and that
there is this distinctly kind
of French historical
image, that's on display.
That is what is distinctly
French about this story.
Although of course there
were examples of, of
of others who collected this
kind of Austin regime style in
in New York and London at the time.
Right? So many of the French, you know
collectors and dealers in
impressionist art were also Jews.
So, you know, it's not to
say that Jews only collect.
That's great.
I was going to say, and
then the other thing is
that in so many other cases,
especially elsewhere in Europe
there is this sort
of very deep relationship
between Jews and modernism.
And, and that's also very much the case in
in the U S for sure
sort of New York and that,
that time around the war.
So it's difficult to say, but I mean
I focused on people who are not doing the
sort of the avant-garde
and the cutting edge.
And, you know, at that time, you know
a lot of other French
collectors had begun to
collect sort of more,
avant-garde more modernist pieces
because of various reasons.
But I, I, I was struck
by the kind of uniformity
of this one particular kind
of social network that is, as I mentioned
all connected and all
related in the commonalities
between what they were buying
and what they were donating
and what that meant as a
kind of collective statement.
So, no, it's not unique
to France in that sense
but I think it bears
a special significance
because it was there in
that particular moment.
Yeah. I thought someone
asked in the questions
about the Edmund a wall
book, and he just came out
with a new book on the chemical
dose, which I just reviewed.
So I just have that very fresh in my mind.
And it's interesting to compare
you guys have complimentary
but slightly different interpretations
of some of these things.
So like that.
And that's an example, I think
so he reads the Kemo DOE
obsession with the 18th century
as a nod to the kind of age of civility
and enlightenment that
emancipated the Jews in a sense.
And you, you, I think do a
very interesting reading of it
which I found very convincing
as a kind of conservative
gesture in theory, public France.
Yeah. I think that's right.
I mean, I, again, I mean
the readers can, can judge
what can we do they think?
But I mean, I think that
it's difficult to say
that it was a nod to the age
that emancipated the Jews
because it's a style that
in fact predates the emancipation
of the Jews in France.
And so, you know, that happened
after the French revolution
you know, during the French revolution
and the style that these
guys are hearkening back
to is the sort of nobility
on the brink before all of that began.
So I, I don't really see
the connection there.
Another, I was gonna say another kind
of interesting divergence
or convergence maybe
of interpretation is in
you both discuss MOEYS to
come on those obsession
with eliminating dust in his
museum and which, you know
he left these like very
detailed instructions for them.
Crazy instructions are really crazy.
Yeah. And so I, you know, so dwell reads
that as a kind of effort
to eliminate the traces
of his Jewish past kind of.
So like dust is the residue
from the past, whereas you give
I think a very fascinating
reading it as kind
of trying to cleanse the, the reputation
in a sense of, of, you know,
these families, you know
that they were, they were
involved in this sort of scandal
this different financial
scandal shortly before
and stuff like that.
- Yeah, sure.
I mean, that's a tough one.
I mean, I think, I mean
it is true that a lot of
these families donated there.
I mean, well, one thing that
I try to mention a little bit
in the book is that the
issue or the question
of your day at the
collections and how that does
and does not intersect
these other collections.
- So he's got rid of his
father's Judaica collect
I would say he did, but
he didn't dispose of it.
He donated it to either
the Ruby, the synagogue
the supported synagogue and the Rue Bufo
where it was to be used in the
in the temple and where
some of it still is.
And then also like the Rothschilds
he donated a lot of the other pieces.
He had to the museum
to Clooney where it was also on display.
So it's not as if and display
I should mention under the name.
So it's not as if the public
is not to see that the Kemo
those were a Jewish family, it's just
that it did not necessarily adhere
to his totalizing vision with
this crazy Versailles fantasy
that he was enacting in the
Hudl cell where he lives.
I mean, that's my read on it.
I mean, I think, look Molly's to chem.
Mondo was not, it was certainly not
in the business of denying his Jewishness.
He literally sued his ex-wife for custody
of their daughter because
she converted to Catholicism
and he did not trust her
to be around a child who
I mean, I mean, it really, I
think that there's a lot there
and he, you know, for instance
when he was outraged that his
son started dating this woman
during the first world,
war was not Jewish.
He was very invested in
maintaining the communal ties.
I think, I mean, also the,
the, the given the kind
of invective of antisemitism
that I mentioned, I mean
the name Cameron DOE was known to readers
of newspapers as a sort
of foreign Jewish name.
And he did not change
the name of the museum.
It's the museum.
And he seemed to chem and DOE I mean
it's not the museum dissolved
the karate, which, you know
or whatever else it's
is named after his son
because I think it's meant to show
that this immigrant family is as proud
of French as proud of
France as anyone else
and as equally able to
understand its genius.
So I don't know, that's
my, I think that that's one
of the things I loved about
your book is you really
give such a nuanced understanding
of French Jewish identity,
you know, so you could look
at these people and on
the surface, and it's true
that some of them like
be it face to come on DOE
but what you really show is that, you know
what might seem like a kind
of disaffection from Judaism
is really just, you know
that there were different ways
of expressing those affiliations and yes
they change over the
course of the 19th century.
They become less traditional,
but it's not a rejection
- Of it.
And it's like another way
of being just another way of being Jewish.
- Yeah. And through this culture
I just thought that was just
very, very beautifully done.
So last question, you
know, that someone's pose
and which I think your
book really raises is
you know, what the, this
lesson has to tell us
about anti-Semitism now in France.
I mean, you are, you know,
you've been living in France
for awhile, you've been
experiencing, I know, or, you know
writing about the rise in antisemitism.
So what does your book have to tell us?
How does it help us
understand the situation?
You know, that is such a good
and complicated question.
You know, I'm not
I'm not really sure I've
thought a lot about this.
My, I don't really know
what the answer is.
I mean, on the one hand,
I think, you know, just
just very briefly antisemitism
today is Besley different
than antisemitism.
Then it has a whole other kind
of discourse and narrative.
It has different origins
and different history to it.
I mean, it really is different.
I mean, now it is.
I mean, it's, again
it's the words are so important in this.
So let me, let me try to
summarize it succinctly
but essentially, you
know, the, the majority
of anti-Semitic violence that we see
in France today is perpetrated
by authors with a similar
cultural background.
And that is often a kind
of third generation
immigrants from Frances
former colonies in north
Africa or west Africa.
And so that is a vastly different, I mean
of course I should say,
you know, there is the
the lingering specter
of the national front
and the sort of its roots
in Holocaust denial, but the
the violent attacks that we see come
from a kind of a different source today.
And, you know, I'm not sure
that it is the same story
or that there really is
a lesson to be drawn.
And it's, it's, it's tricky
because of course, you know
you want to feel like your,
your work will explain kind
of current events, but I'm
not sure that that mine really
does in that sense.
I mean, I, I think one
question that is somewhat
that is the same Maury is of
course the best person here
to explain and to talk more
about, but is the relationship
of particular minority
communities to French universalism
and Maura has written about that.
So well in the right
to difference his book
about French universalism and the Jews.
And that I think is a real
question for French Jews
but especially for French
Muslims these days.
And I think that if, if there
is any parallel, it's more
in that direction than
it is in terms of like
the actual proximate factors
that cause antisemitic violence
in France today.
- Yeah. That's, that's a
great answer to that question.
So a few people have asked
whether this is going to
be recorded and the answer
is yes, and it'll be
available soon on the website.
So we encourage you to
tell people about it
and please join me in
thanking Jake for this really
enlightening, beautiful talk
today, and for the great book
which I encourage you all to read.
So thank you all so much for having me
- Yale University Press discount.
- Yes.
- Okay. Thank you all.
- Thank you so much.
- sure.